it's also an extraordinary time for the
nfl players association because as these
things are unfolding
there's still time for players to vote
on the collective bargaining agreement
the deadline is saturday night 11 59 pm
eastern and an email was sent today to
all agents encouraging them
to make sure their clients vote make
sure they got their ballots make sure
they turn in their ballots and it's all
done electronically and frankly frankly
i think that
the
nflpa board of player representatives
which just a few days ago decided not to
let players change their votes
i think they need to go back and revisit
their votes on whether or not players
should change their votes because a lot
has changed
in the last week since they opened the
window for voting on the cba and now
here we are
and what was the phrase from richard
sherman it was fear of what may happen
that was being used to get people to
vote yes for this cba well some things
have happened over the course of the
last week that may cause players to look
at this cba a little more clearly and
i haven't expressed an opinion on
whether or not players should vote yes
or vote no my prevailing view has been
this players need to understand the
impact of voting yes or voting no
because voting no means i'm voting no to
executive director demora smith of the
nfl pa who negotiated this and who told
me a week ago he's proud of the deal
he's proud of it and former nfl pa
president eric winston proud of it well
winston's out of the picture but smith
isn't
and if you vote no on the deal you're
voting no on demoris smith that's the
position i've taken all along i haven't
said you should go no i haven't said you
should go yes i've said if you're going
to defer to the judgment of the guy that
you hired to do the job yes if you don't
want to defer to his judgment no and
that's a different conversation after
the vote comes back no if it comes back
no now i'm going to tell you given
everything that's happened given all the
reports and everything that's out there
given the way the economy's gone over
the course of the last week or so and
given this brink of uncertainty right
we're standing at the edge of the grand
canyon potentially but we don't know how
deep it is and we don't know how long
it's going to go
given those circumstances if my son
who's 23 and is right about the age that
a young nfl player would be at if he
came to me and he said dad what should i
do about this
i'd say vote yes and there's a very
simple explanation for it
because i've been covering this sport
for 20 years and i know what's going to
happen next
if the end result is no what's going to
happen is there aren't going to be any
negotiations in the near term there
won't be unless the league does push
back the start of the league year and
then there is a window there to maybe
get something done and avoid the rules
the very restrictive rules in free
agency of the final year
of the current cba that would be the
only
exception that would maybe push the two
sides back to the table i think they're
not coming back to the table for a while
the owners are going to want to assess
the full
cost
to themselves to the game to everyone of
this coronavirus situation beyond the
human cost the business cost you see
what the stock market's doing it's down
a thousand points every day it seems
like it was down 2000 the last time i
checked
these owners are losing a lot of money
when they go back to the bargaining
table there is a good chance
that you know that bluster that we saw
it was kind of a clumsy report from espn
that there are some owners that want the
players to vote no because they regret
the deal and they want to go back and
renegotiate it and get a better deal
well that may have been bs on saturday
but again the world has changed in the
last five days right now
my guess would be
that a majority of the owners would say
thank god they voted no
because first of all who knows if the tv
money's going to be there after
everything that's going on the networks
may take a step back and say we want to
see how deep this coronavirus hole is
before we commit hundreds of millions
slash billions of dollars to the nfl
over the next decade so let's just wait
a year that could happen
and the owners may just decide hey you
know what
you didn't take the deal and it was a
great deal and now things have changed
and you're coming back to the bargaining
table and
sorry
we're calling your bluff we're sticking
it to you and if you don't like it hold
out go on strike or we'll lock you out
and we'll see whether or not you cave
either way
i i believe now
and and look
this is where we got to set aside ego
kenny stills last week in the video that
he posted talking about why players
should vote no so we got to puff up our
chest well you know what sometimes when
you puff up your chest someone sticks it
with a needle and it goes flat
this isn't a time for ego this isn't a
time for bravado this isn't a time for
talking tough this isn't a time for
constantly going to twitter and trying
to cajole people into voting no when it
may not be in their best interest to
vote no it's in their best interest to
vote yes
my age my assessment and my judgment
is that this deal that's on the table
right now
the nfl would not put this deal on the
table right now
the deal's on the table circumstances
have changed in a way that makes it less
advantageous to the nfl and i think now
is the time for the players to take it
and run with it
because
they're going to regret i believe not
taking the deal
if the ultimate vote is no and if and
when they go back to the bargaining
table and they find that the owners are
in a much different mood than they've
been for the course of the last year all
right that's it for this special edition
of pft ot look i don't know what's going
to be happening weekdays on pft live we
are trying to keep the staff at a
minimum
at the nbc sports group studio in
stanford connecticut so we may not be on
the air
next week but we will be generating
videos one way or the other whether
someone's there to turn on the camera or
whether i'm using my cell phone device
from this seat and we are all working at
home to get the video content posted we
will have thoughts like this for you to
supplement our writings at
profootballtalk.com and if free agency
begins look i disagree with that but
we'll cover it like we always do and we
will be the one stop shop where you get
all of the news all the information all
the analysis and all the diversion that
you may be looking for as we try to deal
with this dramatic alteration of our
reality and hopefully come together work
toward a solution understand that there
will be better days but also accept the
fact that there will be worse days
before those better days come we'll talk
to you soon and thanks as always for
your support
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports